first time doing 350 baby
[Music]
[Music]
we don't get a chance to do it again let
me show you what the thick life feels
like
thick light
big nation
thick light
big nation
thick light
big nation
[Music]
what's up dickies we're here this
morning a gorgeous day in los angeles
california we got the fan coming in
lifting us my boy mike i don't think
mike's ever missed a show that i've done
locally whether it's at the commie store
the improv the laugh factory ha-ha's the
ice house any show i've ever done my
special years ago in san diego he's come
to it all and he came to show he's like
dude i want to live with you guys so i'm
like get your thick ass to zoo and he's
here today he's lifting with us we hit
some bench i'm gonna go for a pr i don't
feel great about it let's try and hit
430 and then we're gonna do some
deadlift and i'm gonna take his thick
ass to my favorite breakfast spot and
i'm also gonna let him sit in on the
special king of the sting thanksgiving
day edition so he's getting the full
experience man the full mother trucking
experience let's get it uh i went to the
very first fighter in the kid live where
brandon did his first set and uh you
know we hit it off there we talked a
little bit and then i would see him
around town at the store and i had
mentioned that it'd be cool to work out
with him and he said come on down so
here i am and uh looking forward to a
fun day
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i pushed myself a little bit today
and it was fun time man really good time
here over at zoo culture so you know
appreciate brendan and the boys for uh
for hanging with me they're talking
about getting something to eat and then
going to the king of the sting so
looking forward to even more fun stuff
it's going to be dope
look what finally came in kiddos well
not kids not alcoholic beverage but if
you're over 21 it finally came in
straight off the boat from japan finally
your boys whiskey tiger thick finally
hit the shores of the united states
here's the thing though
tastes fantastic two years in the making
ori won awards for the label the muse
creative awards not a big deal
but um you know getting this whiskey
game i thought come out with the whiskey
brendan come out with the whiskey create
great labels great taste and whiskey and
that's just off to the races not so fast
young men not so fast
now the business side comes in because
you can't just ship it and sell it to
everybody like that doesn't work like
that you have to get distribution your
boy learned the hard way so now we're in
the middle of dealing with different
distributors to get it into certain
markets but you don't go nationwide you
start with five markets like dallas
colorado california arizona new york you
see how it goes there and then you
expand from there but you go five major
markets i'm learning on the go you know
new kids in town i'm trying to get my
foot in the door so if you're a
distributor you're a seller holler at
your boy we're doing the work on our end
but uh it's here man and it is fantastic
i'm excited but that's the hustle now
trying to get distribution it's just uh
something i didn't think about
so here we are let's get stopped look at
that baby look at you and some crabbing
now did you have that just sitting
around
like do you have like a like you're like
batman you know everybody's like this is
from home yeah
i assume you have the cone right right
right
you're like someone say thanksgiving
yeah he has like a bookshelf he just
wants to cook
and it's just like
costumes
so i'm thankful for
a roof over my head
i get to eat i get to i can afford
groceries now
like more groceries
um that i'm starting to do stand up now
i'm really grateful for that you know
because i kind of i'm trying to redeem
myself
what else family friends health
those are the main things what's up guys
happy thanksgiving and i'm so thankful
for
just life right now
being on king and sting and all the king
and distinct fans that have been coming
out to the show i'm thankful for you
guys i'm even thankful for you haters
out there too all you troll haters i'm
thankful for you too
happy thanksgiving everyone
i'm thankful
that my grandma who raised me she's
happy and healthy gonna go visit her in
wisconsin over thanksgiving and i'm also
thankful that this is my job i get to go
i get to hang out
as my job so
yeah that's what i'm thankful for happy
holidays everyone oh and thanks for
listening because that's how i have the
job so thank you
tell me what's their motive i can't let
myself get caught up in their emotions i
just put some eyes all on my girl and
now she flexing she gon hold me down
yeah that's my gang yeah that's my best
friend i just put some ice all on my
wrists
what's up guys chapelle lacy here i just
want to talk to you about some things
that i'm thankful for one i'm thankful
for you guys uh for just appreciating
who i am i'm thankful uh for this
wonderful studio to be able to do
chapelle's world and you know
last but not least i'm thankful for you
know
brendan schaub and brian cowan uh just
to be it's just true blessing to be able
to sit down with those guys and uh have
a blast with them every week so thank
you guys happy thanksgiving i'm thankful
for everyone here at the studio
everyone's amazing
i'm thankful to this guy
we've uh done all our shows together
it's freaking i never like sit back and
think about that but we all we've done
like
king and the sting below the belt firing
the kid it's pretty amazing
this year i am thankful that it's gonna
be my i believe my third year here at
fighter and the kid and i'm so thankful
to be here another year working with
everybody i'm really thankful for all
the new team members too it's so great
having our family grow and
yeah the only thing i got to plug is my
feet only fans what's good that's it
okay bye
i'm thankful that i have all my
faculties and more importantly that i
live in a country where i can
realize my potential i get paid off of
what i love to do and that's uh
something i'm always thankful for so
if you want to hear more boring nah
that's uh hey i was trying to be all
deep forget it man get the [ __ ] out of
here
happy thanksgiving all the thickies
worldwide what am i thankful for you ask
um where do i start i'm thankful for
eric stevie the boys come in every week
they're super reliable
i'm thankful for theo even though he
misses all the time but he tries his
best and that's all that matters if he
zooms in or flies in from nashville i'm
thankful for theo thank for brian callan
chappelle lacy chin
kyle the whole squad casey big mike
everybody man thick boys studios we're
doing it we are freaking doing it man
and uh i mean everything you guys see it
takes it takes a whole squad and it's a
whole team i'm in front of the camera
but it's literally an entire team to
make this whole thing function so
i'm excited man i'm thankful for um
you know going to 2022 you guys see a
lot of changes your boy is doing it all
himself
all himself everything i hired my own
staff i bought all the goddamn camera
equipment everything dude i'm doing all
myself from thick boy studios everything
the companions
the rest stuff i can't say right now
because i'd be in trouble but everything
you've seen me do
on every podcast is all coming under one
umbrella thickboy.com think boys studios
that's right son i'm doing all myself so
i'm thankful for
uh just getting it all together man it's
a beast and your boy is exhausted but
it's gonna pay off i'm banking on myself
i've put my entire savings
into paying the staff to get this thing
off the ground
so uh yeah i'm thinking for everything
my girl the kiddos
uh just everything man it's been a great
year and a tough year
and uh that's it man we're doing it
we're doing it i love you guys i should
have had a youtube page a long time ago
finally getting around to it we're
watching new vlogs every week
pretty soon you're gonna have so much
content on think boy you're gonna have
the vlogs my own shows other stuff
you have the fight companions it's gonna
be great casey's laughing because he
knows the inside scoop but uh it's gonna
be great man 2020's would be so [ __ ]
big for your boy and i'm in dania
florida which is fort lauderdale
bringing the new years and there's no
other way i want to bring in a new year
i'm doing stand-up comedy the special
listen i shot it myself i had my crew
shoot it i had my guy shoot it and then
i'm putting it out there everything's on
my own man that's the way it should be
what's up stay thick that's it happy
thanksgiving eat turkey love you guys
everett washington's this [ __ ]
saturday one show one night only all the
boys are coming it's a haunted theater
in everett washington so i might get
possessed so come on out it's gonna be
great i've never been to everett but i
can't wait it's the bowling headquarters
so bowling give the give the boys the
night off because you know just
dudes come to my show so give the boys a
night off girls you know whatever but
bros come on out everett washington see
this saturday take it to
happy thanksgiving